Tja, so klang das damals im Jahr 2012, als Michel Platini, damals noch UEFA-Präsident, der Öffentlichkeit zum allerersten Mal seine Idee präsentierte. Eine Europameisterschaft, die nicht von einem Land als Gastgeber betrieben wird, sondern in mehreren Ländern stattfindet. Und wie ihr hört, hat er auch die vermeintliche Reaktion der Berichtenden vor Ort schon vorweggenommen mit seinem Ah, ja, so hat man damals reagiert. Und jetzt findet genau eine solche EM statt, ohne Michel Platini als UEFA-Präsident. Das ist schon wieder Geschichte. Da sitzt jetzt jemand anderes und auch nicht ganz, so wie es sich Platini vorgestellt hat, ein bisschen weniger Nationen sind es geworden. Aber jetzt haben wir sie eben, diese EM in verschiedenen Ländern. Und da sind durchaus auch Länder mit dabei, die jetzt nicht nur durch Sport aufgefallen sind in der Vergangenheit. Und darum wollen wir uns heute kümmern in diesem Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch Nummer 44, zu dem ich euch ganz herzlich begrüße. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Etkin Etzer bei Twitter und ich freue mich sehr, den perfekten Gesprächspartner für dieses Spiel, für dieses Spiel, für dieses Tribünengespräch zu haben. Ronny Blaschke, er ist freier Journalist und Autor. Er hat geschrieben, unter anderem sein jüngstes Buch Machtspieler Fußball in Propaganda, Krieg und Revolution. Er hat auch geschrieben Gesellschaftsspielchen, Fußball zwischen Hilfsbereitschaft und Heuchelei, sowie zum Beispiel Angriff von Rechtsaußen wie Neonazis, den Fußballmissbrauchen. Also die richtigen gute Launenthemen, die packt sich der Ronny immer raus. Ronny, schön, dass du mit dabei bist im Rasenfunk.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist es auch ganz offensichtlich dem Staat, wenn ich einfach jetzt mal von dem Staat sprechen darf, bewusst, weil es ja dann den Vorfall gab, dass Fans von Besiktas bei einem Derby den Rasen gestürmt haben. Das Spiel wurde abgebrochen, der Verein bestraft. Und später wurde dann bekannt, dass diejenigen, die da gestürmt haben, Verbindungen zur Regierung haben und vielleicht gar nicht jetzt aus dem wirklichen Kern der Fans-Szene von Besiktas kamen. Also da würde ich ja schon fast von der Unterwanderung der Fan-Kultur sprechen, mit dem Zweck, sie zu diskreditieren. Und ja, in dem Fall wurden dann sogar auch Fans vor Gericht gestellt, allerdings alle Vorwürfe dann fallen gelassen.
Das ist interessant, nach solchen Protesten auch in anderen Ländern, lange gelten Ultras für Regierung als Halbstarke, die keine Ahnung haben, die sich da ein bisschen austoben. Aber wenn man dann sieht, was sie für Power entfalten können, dann gelten sie dann plötzlich eben doch als Gefahr für die nationale Sicherheit. Dann kommt die Power des Staates mit dem Geheimdienst, mit der Polizei, mit Einschüchterungsversuchen. Und dann, ja, es gab auch Beispiele aus anderen Ländern, wo dann gezielt solche Gruppen unterwandert werden. Wenn Ultras so einen Heldenstatus einnehmen und in die Popkultur eindringen, dann ist ja klar, dass sie auch neue Mitglieder gewinnen, dass sie auch großes Interesse wecken. Und dadurch wird so eine Gruppe immer wieder auch mal vermischt und dadurch entsteht eine neue Dynamik. Da ist eine sehr, sehr hohe Fluktuation. Das ist auch in Deutschland so, auch in anderen Ländern so. Das ist kein homogener Block und so ist es auch in der Türkei so. Die Menschen, oder es sind ja meistens junge Männer, wachsen irgendwann da auch raus. Und das ist, finde ich, das diskutieren wir auch zu selten. Das sind junge Männer, die im Fußball gewisse Eigenschaften erlernen, die sie dann mitnehmen. Die sie mitnehmen vielleicht in ihren Job, in ihrer, es gibt ja in der Türkei jetzt nicht so viele kritische Parteien, aber das ist eine Wechselwirkung. Fußballfans sind nicht nur Fußballfans, das sind Bürger, das sind Studierende, das sind Arbeiter. Und man kann im Fußball eben auch einiges mitnehmen. Und wenn es nur Mut und Zuversicht ist, das ist da gar nicht so wenig in autokratischen Regimen.
Die Türkei fällt jetzt hier vielleicht ein bisschen raus aus den Ländern, die wir besprechen. Mag vielleicht den ein oder anderen und die ein oder andere schon gewundert haben, denn die Türkei ist ja gar kein Ausrichterland bei dieser Europameisterschaft. Ich kam trotzdem irgendwie nicht an der Türkei vorbei, weil ich so drei Schnittmengen oder Ansatzpunkte sehe, die finde ich auch jetzt ins Hier und Jetzt und auch in diese EM ein bisschen hineinreichen. Das eine ist, das hast du schon kurz angesprochen, eben die wiederholt erfolglose Bewerbung der Türkei um eine Europameisterschaftsaustragung. Letztlich ist man jetzt dann auch für 20, 24 Jahre Deutschland unterlegen. Wie würdest du denn das bewerten bei allem, was wir so wissen, über die Art und Weise, wie diese Turniere vergeben werden, und dass es da jetzt nicht immer nach Fußballbegeisterung oder nach Fußballkultur in den Ländern geht, sondern auch wirtschaftliche und dann sicherlich auch politische Aspekte eine Rolle spielen. Wie würdest du das einordnen, dass die Türkei da jetzt schon mehrfach nicht zum Zug gekommen ist?
Mit den genauen Details, warum das so ist, es waren ja auch starke Bewerber früher. Ich glaube auch, dass früher oder später die Türkei diese Ein-Europameisterschaft auch mal austragen wird. Ich war in der Türkei, es ist natürlich ein tolles, spannendes Land, mit einer fantastischen Geschichte mit Kunst und Kultur. Ich fände es toll, wenn die EM mal in der Türkei wird. Ich würde lieber ein Spiel in Istanbul sehen, als jetzt zum 100. Mal in München. Das ist so mein privates Interesse. Natürlich würde man wieder aufschreien, klar, aus Menschenrechtsgesichtspunkten nicht, aber vielleicht werden wir uns ein bisschen davon lösen und sagen, die akzeptieren einfach mal die Wirklichkeit, dass das vernetzt ist und dass finanzielle Interessen bestehen, aber dass man trotzdem dort spielen kann, wenn man gewisse Regeln erwartet, wenn man Zugeständnisse erwartet, wenn man so viele Journalisten und so weiter mitbringt, Menschenrechtskonzepte. Vielleicht klinge ich da naiv, aber es wäre nicht schlecht. Und gerade wir hier in Deutschland, wo wir viele Menschen haben, mit einer türkischen Einwandere-Biografie, wäre das jetzt nicht so negativ. Also eine EM in der Türkei ist verständlicher als eine WM in Katar, die ein Land mit knapp über zwei Millionen Einwohnern. Aber früher oder später, so viele Interessenten hat die UEFA nicht mehr für dieses Turnier. Mit 24 Teams ist es ein relativ großes Starterfeld. Und nur in England, Frankreich oder Deutschland, das wäre dann irgendwann auch fad.
Und dann gibt es die zweite Schnittmenge zum deutschen Fußball, wo eben Politik und Fußball so eng aneinander haften und auch das zu Diskussionen geführt hat, dass ich das Gefühl hatte, auch wenn es jetzt primär nichts mit dieser Europameisterschaft zu tun hat, kann man es eigentlich kaum rauslassen aus dieser Sendung. Und zwar das Verhältnis von Fußballspielern wie Eker Gündoğan und Mesut Özi zu Erdogan persönlich. Und da gibt es ja auch noch andere, die man nennen könnte. Auch darüber schreibst du im Machtspieler und tust das auf eine differenziertere Art und Weise, als man es an manch anderer Stelle gelesen hat, weil du auch so ein bisschen die Perspektive der Sportler einnimmst. Und dann auch mit ganz guten Gegenbeispielen, unter anderem Hakan Şükür, also wer sich interessiert, wie es dem gerade geht, das mal googeln. Das ist wirklich, ja, da kann man sehen, wie es eben dann im Negativen laufen kann, wenn man sich zu Regime kritisch äußert oder zu Erdogan kritisch in dieser Stelle. So wäre es jetzt korrekt gewesen. Wie würdest du denn jetzt mit etwas Abstand das bewerten? Die Aufregung, die es damals gab vor der WM 2018, rund um das Foto von Erdogan und Özil und Erdogan und Gündogan und jetzt auch die weitere Entwicklung, die diese Beziehung eben zwischen Politiker auf der einen Seite, wenn auch ehemaliger Fußballspieler, und aktiver Profi auf der anderen Seite. Wie würdest du das sehen?
Ja, das ist auch eine Leitfrage. Was dürfen wir eigentlich von Fußballern, was dürfen wir von LeistungssportlerInnen verlangen, wenn sie einen Staat repräsentieren und dafür auch gutes Geld und Öffentlichkeit bekommen? Mesut Özil ist wirklich in alle Richtungen ein gutes Beispiel. Weil der hat ja nicht nur als junger Mann schon, ist er ja als Muslim, nach Mecca gepilgert, hat ein Foto davon gezeigt, das wurde positiv gesehen. Dann kam das Foto mit Erdogan, Shitstorm. Später hat er sich dann für die Uiguren ausgesprochen, also der verfolgte Minderheit in China. Er hat auch für Hongkong was gesagt. Jetzt hat er auch vor kurzem wieder, als der Gaza-Konflikt mit Israel hochgeschnellt ist, eskaliert ist, hat er mit Fenerbahce Istanbul, seinem Verein, ein T-Shirt getragen. Freies Palästina. Das sind alles streitbare Themen. Und von unterschiedlichen Milieus wurde er dafür kritisiert und gelobt. Also immer schwarz oder weiß. Natürlich könnten wir auch mal akzeptieren, wenn jemand nicht unserer Meinung ist. Und deswegen würde ich jetzt mit Abstand sagen, dass die Aufregung nach dem Erdogan-Foto vielleicht doch ein bisschen überzogen war. Und vielleicht sollten wir dahin kommen, dass man vielleicht eher auch an die jüngeren Spieler herangeht. In Sportinternaten, die informiert, denen das Gefühl gibt, dass Fußball doch nicht das Wichtigste ist. Und dass sie früh schon eine Meinung bilden können. Mit Anfang und Mitte 20, wenn alles auf sie einprasselt, kann man ja gar nicht böse sein, wenn sie sich gar nicht mehr äußern. Weil sie es ohnehin nicht allen recht machen können. Und ich finde, es ist oftmals scheinheilig, dass viele Medien verlangen, seid auch mal mündige Sportler, äußert euch zu den Problemen der Welt. Und wenn sie es dann tun, wird es auch aus allen Perspektiven zeredet und klein gemacht. Und Hakan Şükür ist ein gutes Beispiel, einer der Rekord-Nationalspieler in der Türkei, viele Tore gemacht und muss jetzt im Exil in den USA Taxi fahren. Und seine Besitztümer wurden irgendwie beschlagnahmt. Das ist ja auch ein Thema, die Familien leben doch in der Türkei. Und das können wir jetzt nur mutmaßen, was die Familien von Özil, Gündogan und so weiter da vielleicht auch befürchten müssen, wenn sie sich nicht auf die Seite von Erdogan stellen. Das sind die Mutmaßungen. Aber weil wir nur mutmaßen können, vielleicht sollten wir uns da alle vielleicht ein bisschen mehr zurückhalten.
Und dann gibt es eine dritte Schnittmenge zum aktuellen Turnier. Und die kann man auch über Mesut Özil erzählen. Ich weiß nicht, ob du seine Antrittspressekonferenz oder seine Vorstellung damals in der Türkei mitverfolgt hast. Das war ein einigermaßen bizarres Schauspiel. Und da wurde er am Ende auch jetzt nicht gebeten, sondern er hat es einfach getan. Er hat Grüße geschickt an die Soldaten, die in Bakarabakh unterwegs sind und für Aserbaidschan gegen Armenien vorgehen. Und mit Aserbaidschan wiederum sind wir jetzt wieder bei einem EM-Teilnehmer oder Standort gelandet, der eine wichtige Rolle spielt. Kannst du uns mal kurz aufdröseln, wie sind denn die Beziehungen zwischen der Türkei und Aserbaidschan und worum geht es dann da?
Ja, Türkei und Aserbaidschan sind eng verbunden. Das geht natürlich auf eine ganz lange Geschichte zurück, der turksprachigen Völker in Anführungsstrichen. Aserbaidschan natürlich auch in der Vergangenheit im Ostblock, aber jetzt ist das einigende Band die gemeinsame Religion. Und Erdogan hat auch Aserbaidschan unterstützt im wieder aufgeflammten Konflikt um die Region Bekara-Bach. Aserbaidschan und Armenien streiten sich seit langem um diese Region. Und in Aserbaidschan, auch das ist ein autokratisches, vielleicht sogar diktatorisch geführtes Land, Ilyam Aliyev, der Staatschef, der die Macht von seinem Vater übernommen hat, 2003, der über beachtliche Öl- und Gasvorkommen verfügt, der nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion das Land natürlich auch positionieren musste. Das geht nicht nur mit Gas, sondern das soll jetzt auch mit Tourismus funktionieren, weil das Land eben auch eine Wirtschaftskrise durchlebt. Und wie viele andere Staaten funktioniert das mit Veranstaltungen. Da kommen dann Kulturveranstaltungen, da wird auch kleinere Sportereignisse, dann aber auch größere Sportereignisse. Das Finale der Euroleague war da, die European Games waren da, auch islamische Sportspiele waren da, auch kleinere rhythmische Sportgymnastik war auch zu Gast. Und jetzt eben vier Spiele bei der EM in Baku in der Hauptstadt. Erdogan und Aliyev sind enge Vertraute, die türkische Mannschaft für zwei Spiele in der Vorrunde in Baku bestreiten. Da ging die UEFA also auf beide Länder zu, weil Aserbaidschan selbst nicht qualifiziert ist. Das ist sozusagen so ein indirektes Heimspiel, würde ich mal sagen. Ja, und da wird es wirklich klar. Weil Baku spielt, glaube ich, in den europäischen politischen Netzwerken keine große Rolle. Wobei, wenn ich das dazu sage, wirtschaftlich natürlich schon. Man erinnert sich nur an die Verbindung von einigen CDU-Politikern mit Aserbaidschan. Also die machen das schon klug, haben auch Kollegen, Journalisten aufgezeigt, dass da viel Geld ausgegeben wird für Anzeigen, für Werbesports, für positive Stimmung in Europa zu Aserbaidschan. Und wir machen jetzt mit als Fußball-Anhänger.
Ich finde, Aserbaidschan ist so ein bisschen, ich hoffe, dass ich da nicht auf so einen Aktualitätshype-Zug nur mit aufspringe, aber das brisanteste Beispiel von den Ländern, die wir hier besprechen, weil wir hier auch im Kontext des Sports schon gesehen haben, wie die Politik oder die politische Situation vor Ort verhindern und eingreifen kann. Also es will mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz in den Kopf, wie man es einfach akzeptiert, dass Hendrik Mkhitaryan als Kapitän des armenischen Fußball-Nationalteams und bei dem Konflikt rund um die Region Bergkarabach geht es um Armenien versus Aserbaidschan. Und da wurde ein Krieg geführt, der jetzt zwar beendet ist, aber er hat verzichtet, das Europa League-Finale in Baku zu bestreiten, aus Angst um seine Sicherheit. Und wie viel mehr rote Flagge muss es denn geben, dass ein Spieler sagt, ich fühle mich hier nicht sicher genug, um hier ein Finale, ein wichtiges Spiel in meiner Karriere zu bestreiten? Und im Grunde kann ihm ja auch keiner widersprechen. Es war jetzt nicht so, dass die Reaktionen waren, ach komm, da macht er ja aus einer Mücken-Elefanten so eine Direktion. Ja, stimmt, ist tatsächlich ein bisschen doof mit diesem Finale im Baku. Und jetzt, zwei Jahre später, und eigentlich wäre es ein Jahr später gewesen, die EM wurde ja verschoben aus anderen Gründen, finden dann eben EM-Spiele dort statt.
European Games 2015 war ein ähnlicher Fall. Da haben ja auch deutsche Sportler mitgemacht. Und nach langen Verhandlungen ist auch eine armenische Delegation dorthin gereist. Massive militärischer Schutz für die armenischen Sportler, also das sind wirklich die Erzfeinde schlechthin. Und jetzt auch wieder wurden ja auf beiden Seiten Menschenrechtsverletzungen oder Kriegsverbrechen auch dokumentiert bei dem jüngsten Konflikt 2020 zwischen Armenien und Azerbaijan. Und wenn man auch schaut, ja, Ilya Maliev hat sich vor kurzem noch in einem neuen Museum präsentiert, wo aufgereihte Helme von gefallenen armenischen Soldaten ausgestellt sind, wo die armenischen Feinde sozusagen sehr karikaturenhaft dargestellt werden, wo Kriegsgerät inszeniert wird. Das gibt es auch in anderen Ländern, aber jetzt besonders prominent in Azerbaijan. Und das scheint sich sicher zu fühlen. Kurz vor einer Euro, der will natürlich auch provozieren, vielleicht ein bisschen. Spannend ist auch, dass der erfolgreichste Verein Aserbaidschans kulturelle Wurzeln in der Region Bekarabakh hat. In der Stadt Akdam, Anfang der 90er Jahre, nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion, als es wieder ausbrach, der Krieg und die Stadt Akdam damals zerstört wurde, sind die Fußballer von dort nach Baku geflohen. Der Verein Karabakh hat jetzt einige Meisterschaften hintereinander gewonnen, spielt auch hin und wieder in europäischen Wettbewerben, wird auch überdurchschnittlich unterstützt, weil er eben das Symbole ist für Phoenix aus der Asche, aus der Kriegsregion ist er entstanden. Der Pressesprecher von Karabakh hat vor kurzem auch bei Facebook geschrieben, sinngemäß, wir müssen ausnahmslos alle Armenier töten, wurde dafür auch lebenslang gesperrt. Also auch ganz andere auf beiden Seiten, aber besonders in Aserbaidschan, viele Spieler haben in sozialen Medien salutiert für die Armee, für das Militär, Opfer wurden gedacht, Tribünen wurden mit aserbaidschanischen Flaggen überspannt. Also die Symbolik ganz klar im Fußball breit ausgestellt.
Aber warum finden dann dort EM-Spiele statt? Wie ist das zu begründen?
Die Entscheidung ist ja sicherlich vorhergefallen. Und letztendlich ist das bei uns auch gar nicht so groß diskutiert worden. Klar, der Konflikt bei Karabach, den haben viele letztes Jahr zum ersten Mal überhaupt davon gehört. Das hat erst mal ein bisschen gedauert, das zu verstehen von zwei Ländern, die jetzt aus unserer Sicht in der Peripherie liegen. Und dann wird natürlich immer gesagt, soll da EM stattfinden? Aber mit den genauen Hintergründen, die habe ich jetzt gar nicht so intensiv wahrgenommen. Und ja, dann, wie würde es theoretisch dann laufen? Wer würde protestieren? Dann kann der DFB was sagen als größter Sportfachverband. Dann könnte auch vielleicht die FA was sagen in England. Die hat auch Einfluss. Dann könnte der FC Bayern was sagen oder die großen Clubs. Habe ich alles nicht gehört. Und wir beide oder auch das beachtliche Publikum, was wir jetzt haben, oder auch andere, das wird nicht reichen leider. Deswegen müssen wir vielleicht da Mehrheiten für unsere Themen gewinnen. Und ich stelle mir die Frage auch immer, aber ich wüsste nicht, wer sie irgendwie überhaupt aufwerfen sollen würde. Es gibt keine oder es gibt nicht ausreichende, wie soll ich sagen, Klauseln in diesen Ausrichtervertregen, die besagen, so, wenn ihr jetzt im nächsten Krieg beginnt, dann bekommt ihr die Spiele entzogen. Ich glaube nicht, dass das in dem Ausrichtervertrag steht.
Ganz so habe ich es jetzt gar nicht gemeint. Das ist quasi dann schon die Frage, warum es jetzt dann darum kein großes Aufhebenskipp, zumindest jetzt meiner Beobachtung nach, sondern die Frage, meinte ich eigentlich dahingehend, ist es jetzt wieder mit, in Anführungszeichen, nur mit Geld zu begründen, dass die UEFA dann Baku als Sportstandort wahr ernst nimmt. Das ist ja nicht nur der Fußball, sondern auch die Formel 1 ist ja unter anderem vor Ort da. Du hast vorhin schon Soccer angesprochen, den Energiekonzern, den niemand kannte. Und auf einmal war er UEFA-Sponsor. Und wer ihn gegoogelt hat oder Ecosiat hat, hat dann herausgefunden, aha, okay, da führen die Wege nach Aserbaidschan. Also ist die Wahrheit dann so einfach, dass man sagen muss, naja, die haben halt sehr, sehr viel Geld. Und deshalb sind sie dann interessant auch für einen Sportverband. Weil ansonsten gibt es ja, anders als zum Beispiel bei Russland, sehr wenig Gründe, die dafür sprechen, irgendein Event in Aserbaidschan stattfinden zu lassen.
Ja, also das Geld ist natürlich ein Grund, auch die Vernetzung, neue Märkte zu erschließen. Und was ich auch erst mal lernen musste, dass es glaube ich wirklich parallel Universen sind. Die Debatten, die wir jetzt vielleicht führen, oder auch in einigen Medien Westeuropas, ja schon gar nicht mehr in Ungarn oder in Tschechien oder in Baltikum, sondern in Deutschland, in Großbritannien, in Frankreich, vielleicht noch in Spanien. Die Debatten, die da, oder auch in Skandinavien, die dort geführt werden, ich glaube, die erreichen manchmal gar nicht die Gremien. Vielleicht noch den Präsidenten, Cheferin, der interviewt das regelmäßig, aber die Leute im UEFA-Exekutivkomitee, oder die sagen, gehen wir noch weiter, die FIFA, ich weiß nicht, ob die jetzt die Artikel im Guardian lesen, wenn sie von 5 Sterne zu Hotel zu 5 Sterne Hotel fahren, sich unabhängig fühlen, sich reich fühlen, jahrelang mit Korruption durchgekommen sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob das die nicht eher sogar langweilt. Das ist eine bittere Erkenntnis eigentlich, dass wir uns hier abstampeln können, informieren können. Und letztendlich, klar, unsere Bubble wird größer, die kritische Bubble wird größer, aber es ist immer noch eine Bubble, gemessen daran, dass Spieler wie Manuel Neuer oder Ronaldo oder andere Millionen, dutzende Millionen Menschen über soziale Medien erreichen. Und da spielt das Politische gar keine Rolle. Also das sind Paralleluniversen. Und die fragen sich auch nicht jetzt, ob das Spiel in Baku stattfindet, sondern das könnte auch auf dem Mond stattfinden. Sie gucken die EM und Sie gucken die WM. Und das ist eine bittere Erkenntnis. Aber ich will auch nicht zu negativ sein, das wird ja größer. Und die Kritik ist über die Jahre langsam größer geworden. Und es führt immer noch dazu, dass von diesen zwölf großen Sponsoren der EM jetzt vier aus China kommen, eine aus Katar. Soka ist nicht mehr Sponsor, aber es sind vier aus China. Klar, ist das schwierig zu erklären beim europäischen Turnier, aber so ist es. Und das wird vermutlich auch noch weiter zunehmen.
Ja, und andererseits, ich fand erstmal das Beispiel Manuel Neuer ganz interessant, weil er sich ja nicht mal dann politisch äußert, wenn er sich politisch geäußert hat, ohne es zu wissen. Er hat ja da ein Lied gesungen, was dann vielleicht im Nachhinein nicht so schlau war und hat sich danach dann eher lustig gemacht über die Aufregung darüber. Das war dann auch schon ein sehr deutliches Zeichen der zumindest persönlichen Ignoranz gegenüber manchen Konflikten, die es da gibt. Das muss dann jeder selber bewerten, wie er das findet. Aber was ich bei Aserbaidschan so interessant finde, so spannend finde, ist, ich habe das Gefühl, und da darfst du mich jetzt aber auch gerne korrigieren, wenn du es komplett anders siehst, dass wir da eine andere Wertigkeit haben, als eben zum Beispiel, wenn in Russland ein Sportevent stattfindet. Oder auch meinetwegen in der Türkei mit gewissen Abstufungen noch. Denn Aserbaidschan war doch gar nicht so ähnlich wie Katar vor zehn Jahren. Die waren doch gar nicht auf der sportpolitischen Landkarte und auch nicht auf der touristischen Landkarte. Und genau auf die sind sie ja draufgekommen mit diesen Sportevents. Hat das dann nicht nochmal eine andere Wertigkeit, wenn man sagt, wir unterstützen jetzt quasi schon sehenden Auges die Anfänge und wir wissen ja, welche Ziele damit verfolgt werden. Und jedes Land darf seine eigenen Ziele verfolgen. Das ist ja völlig klar. Aber wenn man dann eben aus guten Gründen bei vielleicht Aserbaidschan sagt, also das ist jetzt aber nicht etwas, was man unterstützen möchte, dann könnte man das ja auch, druff gesagt, auch ganz einfach abdrehen, indem man einfach dahin keine Sportereignisse vergibt.
Ja, Aserbaidschan, ich würde gar nicht sagen, die haben schon einige Sportereignisse auch gehabt. Auch Architektur, da haben renommierte westliche Architekten, haben dort Zentren und Gebäude gebaut. In der Kunst ist es auch so, in der Musik ist es auch so. Das Geld spielt da eine große Rolle. Und es ist auch in so einer Peripherie nicht ganz so zentral. Geopolitisch ist Aserbaidschan, vielleicht jetzt auch aus europäischer Sicht, nicht so ein heikles Thema, auch wenn die mit der Türkei zusammenarbeiten. Im Süden grenzt Iran und Aserbaidschan. Das ist einfach bei uns nicht ganz so auf der Agenda. Ich würde gerne die Frage, wie entscheiden das ja nicht? Das entscheidet ja die UEFA, die anderen Sportverbände. Der Internationale Eishockey-Verband, das ist ein Schweizer, führt den aus einer stolzen Demokratie, die auf direkte Demokratie seit Langem setzt. Und der hat immer noch ganz, ganz spät Lukaschenko getroffen und ihn umarmt und wollte ganz, ganz spät auf öffentlichen Druck die Eishockey-WM dort entziehen. Und der hat auch kritische, ich gebe mal davon aus, die kritischen Medienberichte wahrgenommen. Warum der das nicht macht, das frage ich mich auch. Ob die da in anderen Netzwerken sind oder anderen Werte kanonen, das frage ich mich auch. Weil der kommt ja nicht aus China oder aus Russland oder aus Uzbekistan, sondern er ist ein Schweizer und ist in Europa sozialisiert. Als Menschen dort geknebelt, gefoltert, verhaftet wurden, wollte immer noch die Eiswerke WM in Belarus stattfinden lassen.
Man wird es vielleicht nie erfahren. Vielleicht noch interessant zu wissen für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, es gibt eine Sonderregel der UEFA, nach dem Clubs und Nationalteams aus Armenien und Aserbaidschan nicht gegeneinander spielen dürfen. Das erscheint logisch, aber zeigt ja auch, wie tief da die Gräben sind, wenn nicht mal der Sport, der immer die ganze Welt vereint, zumindest im Marketing spreche, der großen Verbände, wenn nicht mal der Sport es schafft, diese politischen Gräben zu überwinden. Aber dann wisst ihr, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, was es noch zu Baku als Austragungsort zu wissen gibt, auch wenn die Bilder von da werden toll sein. Die Architektur, die du auch schon angesprochen hast, das sieht alles ganz fantastisch aus. Dahinter steckt aber halt dann noch ein bisschen mehr, wie leider so häufig. Wir gießen ein bisschen Wasser in die EM-Suppe, aber so muss es dann vielleicht auch manchmal sein. Wir haben mit Ungarn und Budapest noch einen Standort, an dem auch EM-Spiele ausgetragen werden. Der ist jetzt wieder auch geopolitisch und auch politisch näher an Deutschland heran. Und auch hier sind wir, glaube ich, wieder sehr schnell in einer Diskussion, welche Maßstäbe wir eigentlich anlegen an Austragungsorte. Ich finde Ungarn aber auch deshalb jetzt relevant, weil Ungarn auch generell eine Rolle gespielt hat rund um die Corona-Pandemie. Wir alle erinnern uns an die Spiele zwischen Liverpool und Raber Leipzig, die bei einer Inzidenz von 300 in Budapest stattgefunden haben, einfach weil Willy Orban gesagt hat, das ist alles hier gar kein Problem, kommen Sie gerne, Sie können gerne Ihre Spiele hier machen, wenn die in den anderen Ländern da irgendwelche Einreisebeschränkungen und so weiter haben. Bei uns gibt es das nicht. Ist das so ein Zeichen für einen fast schon pragmatischen Ansatz, wie man sich über den Fußball dann politisch, sportpolitisch positionieren kann?
Ja, also Orban ist als Ministerpräsident innerhalb der Europäischen Union. Stark in der Kritik wird so als nationalistische Außenseite angesehen, weil er Justiz, weil er Medien, weil er Zivilgesellschaft stark an die Leine nimmt und stark in der Kritik ist. Er ist ein großer Fußballfan, hat selbst auch Fußball gespielt. Wenn man das bei Google mal eingibt, Orban, Football, sieht man lustige Fotos, war auch ein passabler Spieler. Und die Legende ist ja auch, dass er mit seinen Gründern, der Fidesz, der seiner Partei 80er, 90er Jahre im selben Team gespielt hat und in seiner Heimatstadt, in einer kleinen Stadt, auch da ist ein wunderschönes Stadion entstanden, in vielen ungarischen Städten, schöne Stadien, Sportakademien, Hallen entstanden, für viel Geld, da gibt es auch Kritik, warum man nicht genauso viel Geld in Bildung oder Medizin steckt. Aber Viktor Orban als Ministerpräsident, der ist Fußballfan. Und klar, durch solche Gesten, wie das England oder das Deutschland die Einreisebestimmung während Corona verschärfen, aber Ungarn macht die Türen auf für Sport, trotz hoher Inzidenz, vielleicht hat er dafür auch Geld genommen, das Stadion in Budapest zu vermieten. Es ist auch so, dass seine Vertrauten in den Clubs sitzen. Manchmal muss man dem vielleicht gar nicht immer nur böse Strategie unterstellen, sondern es sind wirklich leidenschaftliche Fußballer, die mögen den Sport und die wollen sich da das auch als Spielball, als Spielzeug halten. Ich kann empfehlen von David Goldblatt, ein britischer Autor, der hat The Age of Football geschrieben und schreibt auch für den Guardian. Der beschreibt das ganz gut. Die wollten schon lange mal mit Orbán sprechen und sind dann zum Fußball gefahren. Und im Stadion auf der Ehrentribüne ist die Chance, mit noch am größten ihn mal ansprechen zu können. Das gilt auch für andere Politiker. Und auch in Ungarn, das wissen wir, Rechtsruck, Minderheiten, Sinti und Roma, jüdische Menschen, die haben es schwer. Und Ferdinz Varos Budapest, der Rekordmeister, auch da sitzt ein Orbán-Vertrauter seit zehn Jahren an der Spitze. Auch dort ist es auch wie in anderen Ländern so, wenn mal kritische Leute auf die Straße gehen, dann kann man eben auch mit den eigenen Fans, mit den eigenen manchmal auch extrem rechten Fans, da Drecksarbeit verrichten lassen, dass das nicht zu kritisch wird. Aber Ungarn ist wirklich ein Beispiel in der Europäischen Union, wie der Fußball da genutzt wird. Und das geht so weit, dass das Orbán ja, das Wort Geopolitik kann man durchaus verwenden, der möchte ja auch in den Nachbarstaaten einen Einfluss gewinnen. Im Süden von Ungarn, in Kroatien, im Osten von Kroatien, in Osttiek. Auch dort ist mit ungarischen Firmen, nicht nur mit ungarischen Firmen, auch mit anderen, auch ein neues Stadion entstanden. Und wenn man von Viktor Orbán seine Reden hört, der träumt ja schon oft von diesem großen Ungarn, was es ja mal gegeben hat im Königreich Ungarn, also Anfang noch des 20. Jahrhunderts. Es war ja mal ein wesentlich größeres Land, und dann ab und zu sagt er mal sowas, und dann hört man in Kroatien auch genau hin. Wird nicht ganz ernst genommen, aber ist schon irritierend. Und der Fußball ist da auch eine Bühne, das auch zu zeigen. Wenn Ungarn eben auch im Nachbarland Stadion baut.
Da stecken jetzt schon wieder so viele Themen drin. Ich vermute, die Hörerinnen und Hörer sind vor allem über den Einsatz von oft sehr rechten Hooligans aus politischen Gründen so ein bisschen drüber gestolpert. Wir erleben bei Ungarn ja ein bisschen einen, oder was heißt ein bisschen? Ich versuche immer diplomatisch zu sein, vielleicht bin ich manchmal an den falschen Stellen. Wir erleben einen Rechtsruck und auch das systematische Nivellieren von demokratischen Institutionen, wie eben zum Beispiel einer freien Presselandschaft. Das alles erleben wir bei einem EU-Mitgliedstaat, bei dem sich zwar der Staatschef jetzt immer mehr isoliert, aber de facto immer noch mit sehr, sehr vielen Dingen nicht nur mitreden kann, sondern auch mitbestimmen kann in der Europäischen Union. Würdest du denn sagen, man kann das auch am Fußball ablesen, was in Ungarn gerade passiert? Du hast ja gerade auch schon ein drastisches Beispiel genannt.
Es ist fast, würde ich sagen, so ein Vergrößerungsglas. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass Ungarn macht politisch der wichtigste Staat innerhalb der Europäischen Union ist. Und die Fußballliga ist jetzt auch nicht die spektakulärste Liga. Ungarn zählt von seiner glorreichen Geschichte der 50er Jahre. Aber jetzt bei der EM ist er ein Standort. Und noch einmal, klar wird sich Viktor Orbán freuen, dass er da jetzt auf der Bühne ist. Der hat nicht die Allmachtsfantasie, einer der wichtigsten Staatschefs in Europa zu sein. Auf seine Region schaut er schon, auf die Nachbarstaaten. Aber er ist kein Macron und auch keine Merkel. Das weiß er auch. Er ist auch kein... Ich spreche kein Ungarisch, aber was man von Experten so hört, spricht er ja nicht so wie Putin. Oder er gibt sich anders. Aber seinen Laden hat er schon im Griff, um das mal salopp zu formulieren. Sonst würde er nicht nach und nach die Strukturen so sehr verändern. Er ist ja auch schon 11 Jahre an der Macht. Er wird vermutlich auch noch länger an der Macht bleiben, weil er nach und nach alle Strukturen mit Vertrauten austauscht. In den Medien, in der Justiz, in der Kultur, in der Bildung. Es ist quasi bald ein Parteienstart. Wie gesagt, der Fußball ist ein besonders emotionales, ein besonders reichweitenstarkes Vermittlungsmedium für diese Taktik.
Womit man dann ja auch ableiten könnte, wahrscheinlich ist für Viktor Orban die Innenwirkung, dass solche Fußballereignisse in Ungarn stattfinden, wichtiger als die Außenwirkung. Du hast ja schon gesagt, er will wahrscheinlich gar nicht der große Staatsmann sein und weiß auch um die geopolitische Situation. Also würdest du da zustimmen, dass es vor allem darum geht, nach innen ein Zeichen der Stärke zu setzen und sich dann eben auch hinter einem emotionalen Ereignis zu vereinen?
Es ist schwierig, das genau zu vermuten, was er damit genau denkt. Und er ist jetzt auch an einem Punkt, wo er die Macht sicher hat und da kritische Köpfe nicht mehr so zu fürchten hat, wie noch vor einigen Jahren. Und ja, die Medien haben diese Gastspiele, die deutschen Clubs als europäische Solidarität gefeiert, die nicht mehr unabhängigen Medien, zumindest die größeren, da wird sich zeigen auf der EM-Bühne. Und jetzt, wenn der Ball erst mal rollt, wenn die kritischen Beiträge und Interviews vorbei sind, dann werden sich viele Medien auch wieder Zeit nehmen über das ungarische Nationalteam der 50er Jahre, die glorige Zeit, der Pushkast usw. Da wird es wieder ein bisschen weicher. Auch das ist interessant, wo es auch wenig Studien gibt, die das vielleicht bemessen können, ob der Fußball in seiner Öffentlichkeit zu einer tatsächlichen Wertschöpfung beiträgt. Da hat Budapest aus touristischen Gründen das nicht nötig. Es ist eine beliebte und aus Westeuropa stark frequentierte Stadt. Aber auch Ungarn ist ja, auch das frage ich mich jetzt, das ist meine westeuropäische Brille, warum macht das der Orban? Warum geht er in so vielen Punkten auch auf Konfrontation mit der EU? Obwohl er ja in den EU-Fördertöpfen so stark von diesem gemeinsamen Netzwerk abhängt. Aber es scheint zu funktionieren und im Fußball wird er dafür jetzt auch ein bisschen belohnt.
Und dann haben wir ja hier jetzt auch schon eine Schnittmenge des Fußballs zu Rechten bzw. nationalen Tendenzen. Du hast dich ja damit auch schon ausführlich befasst, auch im deutschen Fußball. Würdest du sagen, da ist der Fußball besonders anfällig, für da ein Publikum anzuziehen oder ein Publikum zu haben, das eben auch einem solchen Gedanken gut anhaftet? Oder liegt das jetzt einfach nur daran, was der beliebteste Sport in Europa ist? Und wir hätten das im Basketball in Lettland zum Beispiel, da ist ja Basketballgröße genauso.
Fußball ist seit Jahrzehnten, seit mehr als 100 Jahren in vielen Ländern, die mit Abstand beliebteste Sportart, da konnten sich ganz andere Narrative herausbilden. Und auch in Ungarn und auch in anderen Ländern im östlichen Europa ist es vor allem überwiegend männlich. Es ist in Ungarn, ähnlich wie in Polen oder in der Ukraine, noch nicht so ein Familienevent wie bei uns. Es gibt auch keine Fanprojekte oder wenig linke zivilgesellschaftlich orientierte Ultras. Es ist ein überwiegend männliches, maskulines, chauvinistisches Klientel, was natürlich auch der Sport an sich, das wir gegen die anderen, die Abgrenzung, die Provokation, das ständige Provokante im Spiel, das führt vielleicht auch dazu. Aber es sind dann eben auch, wenn wir mal in Ungarn bleiben, gewisse Milieus, die auch das, jedes Land muss man historisch für sich dann auch betrachten. Auch Ungarn, die es nicht ganz leicht gehabt haben nach dem Zusammenbruch des Ostblocks, auch Korruption in der Regierung. Und dann kam Victor Orban und man kann da auch in die jüngere Geschichte schauen, als er um die Nullerjahre herum dann auch, da gab es ja auch turbulente Szenen, Stürmungen vom Rundfunksender und so weiter. Da waren schon Fußball-Fans dabei. Es war so eine Art auch rechtloser Raum und das konnte man dann weiterentwickeln. Wie gesagt, bei Ferenc Varrocs sitzt ein vieles Vertrauter und auch da haben tolle Kollegen in Ungarn darüber recherchiert und zeigen die Vernetzung. Das sieht man auch in Russland oder auch in den westlichen Balkanstaaten noch mehr, wie sehr Politik und Fußball und dieses junge männliche Publikum da vernetzt ist. Das gibt Vermischung auch mit dem Rotlichtmilieu, Leute, die als Türsteher in Diskotheken arbeiten, die auch in anderen Formen Geld verdienen, was illegalerweise. Die gehen auch zum Fußball, das sind auch Fans, und kann man dann vielleicht relativ leicht auch für extrem rechte oder rechtspopulistische Organisationen gewinnen.
Das martialische, das der Fußball oft hat, kommt ja sicherlich auch noch mit dazu. Aber könnte das nicht ein Ansatzpunkt sein, wenn man jetzt sagt, wir verlangen vom Fußball, in dem Fall wäre es jetzt dann vom Verband UEFA, dass er eben sich schon für mehr einsetzt als nur einem ökonomischen Gewinn in Turnieren, sondern eben auch für eben zivilgesellschaftliche Aktionen, dass das eben zum Beispiel ein Kriterium werden könnte, dass Ausstragungsorte von Turnieren, dass es da Fanprojekte geben muss, dass ein gewisser Teil der Gelder, die eingenommen werden, auch genau dafür verwendet werden. Ich hoffe, da bin ich jetzt nicht so blauäugig, aber ich hätte jetzt die These aufgestellt, dass das im Grunde das einzige ist, was gegen solche rechten Tendenzen innerhalb von Fanszenen nachhaltig wirken kann, wenn man eben für Fanprojekte sorgt, wenn man die Jugendlichen versucht frühzeitig aufzuklären und zu versuchen, dass nicht jeder da sofort in diese Szene hineinrutscht, sondern dass es auch eine Alternative dazu gibt.
Wir kennen und vermutlich können viele von den Hörerinnen das gar nicht mehr hören und sehen, diese Symbolik gegen Racism oder für Vielfalt usw. Diese ewig gleiche Agentursprache, die manchmal auch sehr leer und vage erscheint. Und klar, Symbolik ist gut und sollte ein Mindeststandard sein, aber überdeckt manchmal ja auch die wahren Probleme, weil es vielleicht sogar der unwissenden Publikumsmehrheit suggeriert, die Bosse kümmern sich und wir müssen es selbst nicht machen. Deswegen, wie du sagst, Symbolik macht nur Sinn, wenn es auch mit Inhalten unterfüttert wird. Und wie in Deutschland mehr als 60 Fanprojekte entstanden sind, wo Sozialarbeiter den Fußball als Lockmittel nutzen, um junge Männer vor allem, aber auch Frauen und Mädchen für Jugendhilfe zu gewinnen. Das hat man auch zum Beispiel versucht vor der EM 2008 in Österreich und der Schweiz auch ein bisschen vor Polen und Ukraine 2012. Es ist dort weniger geglückt, aber klar kann man das ganz leicht auch mit einbeziehen in die Ausrichterverträge als Bedingung knüpfen. Und das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, von dem ich glaube, dass nicht nur diese moralischen Idealistischen Reden oder diese Worte wie Fair Play, die leider so inflationär benutzt werden. Wir reden hier von einer Milliardenindustrie, von einem Wirtschaftszweig, der muss einfach straff organisiert werden. Soziales oder politisches, gesellschaftlich relevantes und Geld verdienen müssen sich nicht ausschließen. Man darf auch mit einem Sponsor gemeinsam ein Projekt entwickeln für Klimaschutz oder gegen Rechtsextremismus. Denn es sind nicht NGOs, die das sagen haben, oder Sozialprojekte, die das sagen haben, sondern es sind Rechteinhaber, es sind Bierbrauereien, es sind Wettanbieter, es sind Fluggesellschaften aus den Golfstaaten, die haben das Sagen im Fußball. Und denen fehlt jetzt ohnehin so eine richtige Glaubwürdigkeit, aber auch die müssen eine moderne Gesellschaftspolitik haben. Kann man sagen, waschen die sich damit rein? Ja, aber es gibt vielleicht doch einen Mittelweg. Ich bin pragmatischer geworden in den vergangenen Jahren, weil man sich den Idealismus ein bisschen abtrainiert. Aber es ist eine Kommerzbranche, wo man, glaube ich, kommt in die Vorzimmer von Schäferin, von Infantino, von Rummenigge oder Watzke, nur herein, wenn man sagt, hey, wir haben eine gute Idee, da erreichen wir Menschen und wir können auch ein bisschen Geld damit verdienen. Und wenn das sich irgendwann da durchsetzt, dann ist vielleicht allen irgendwie auch ein bisschen geholfen.
Wobei mit sowas wie Fanprojekten jetzt eher schwer Geld zu verdienen wäre, es wäre eher so ein Verteilen von Geldströmen. Aber teilst du denn meinen Optimismus, dass das ein wirksames Mittel sein kann? Ich meine, man kann ja auch im deutschen Fußball, wir müssen jetzt ja nicht so tun, als ob hier alles ganz toll wäre, als ob wir keine rechten Fanszenen hätten. Da kann man ja sowohl Pro- als auch Contra-Beispiele finden für die These. Fanprojekte können helfen, diese Strukturen ein bisschen aufzubrechen.
Es zeigt in der Landkarte der Fanprojekte dort, wo früh Fanprojekte arbeiten durften, wo sie finanziert wurden, auch von der Kommune, vom Land und vom DFB, wie in Bremen, wie in Leverkusen, wie in Hamburg, wie in Dortmund, dass dort Erfolge sich gezeigt haben, dass Sozialarbeiterinnen, die brauchen lange, um Beziehungen aufzubauen mit jungen Fußballfans, das kostet Zeit. Und in anderen Städten, wo dann relativ spät es sich dazu entschlossen wurde, gibt es immer noch mal Probleme. Aber auch da ist eine hohe Fluktuation, da sind wenige Leute, für viele Fans, das ist eine undankbare Arbeit. Aber es ist ein Beispiel. Das Problem ist auch, sobald wir jetzt in Dresden dann wiederholigens den Aufstieg mit Ausschreitungen auch teilweise begehen, dann kommt die Kritik, wir haben noch ein Fanprojekt, warum gibt es immer noch diese Gewalt? Dadurch entsteht ein Handlungsdruck auf die Sozialarbeiter. Und natürlich ein nicht gezeigter Hitlergruß lässt sich eben schwer als Erfolg verbuchen. Das ist der Nachfall von Prävention. Aber trotzdem glaube ich schon, dass das Früchte trägt, sonst würden andere Länder wie Frankreich, auch wie England, die auch einen anderen Weg gehen, da nicht so neidisch auf die Fanprojekte schauen. Und natürlich gibt es Entwicklungspotenzial, auch die Fanprojekte, haben lange wenig gegen Sexismus gemacht usw. Und wenn wir nach Ungarn oder nach Russland schauen, dann glaube ich, ist der deutsche Fußball wirklich passabel aufgestellt.
Jetzt war jetzt ein kleiner Schwenker. Einen großen Schwenker haben wir noch vor uns. Es ist ein bisschen ein wilder Ritt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich gebe es zu, durch viele verschiedene politische Themengebiete. Ich kann nur nochmal darauf hinweisen, das Buch Machtspieler von Ronny sich zu besorgen und zu lesen. Da bekommt ihr das nochmal ein bisschen in mehr Ruhe und mehr Tiefe vermittelt. Wir sind bei nationalistischen Tendenzen im Fußball. Dann müssen wir noch über zwei Besonderheiten sprechen, die auch mit dieser EM zu tun haben, jetzt aber nicht mehr auf Ausrichterebene. Das eine ist, dass es separatistische Bewegungen auch in Ländern wie Spanien gibt und dass wir Nationalismus im Umfeld von Fußballvereinen, ich würde sagen in einer schon extremeren Form als anderswo, in vielen Ländern des ehemaligen Jugoslawiens erleben. Das ist jetzt eine sehr große Klammer, die ich hier mache. Aber welche Rolle spielt denn da die Verquickung von Politik und Fußball deiner Meinung nach?
Einige Spiele der EM sollten ja ursprünglich in Bilbao stattfinden. Und auch das spanische Nationalteam sollte dort spielen, was ich immer schon als kurios empfunden habe, weil das spanische Nationalteam seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr in Bilbao gespielt hat. Da wären sie vermutlich ausgefiffen worden, im Bastenland. Sogar die Einschaltquoten des Nationalteams sind im Bastenland geringer als in anderen Regionen Spaniens. Weil das Bastenland, wie andere Regionen, aber vor allem das Bastenland, seit Jahrzehnten stolz ist auf seine relative Autonomie. Viele wollen sich sogar ganz loslösen von Spanien. Der Fußball bei Athletic Bilbao vor allem war eng verknüpft mit der Baskischen Nationalistenpartei. Schon 20er, 30er Jahre waren Politiker auch in den Vorständen von Athletic Bilbao und auch in der Diktatur in Spanien unter Franco, die ja rund 40 Jahre andauerte. Vielleicht ist das ein bisschen auch Mythos und Verklärung, aber zumindest konnte man auch ein bisschen die baskische Kultur beim Fußball in der gefühlten Anonymität des Stadions dann auch ausleben. Als Franco gestorben war und das erste Derby danach, oder ich glaube kurz, es war um den Tod herum von Franco in der Mitte der 70er Jahre, Adidik Bilbao gegen Real Sociedad aus San Sebastian, also der zweite große baskische Club. Da haben beide Kapitäne die baskische Flagge in den Anstoßpunkt gerammt. Wenn man heute durch Bilbao geht, da kommt dann diese Szene immer mal wieder entgegen. Das ist diese verklärende Art, was man sich als Mythos wahrscheinlich immer größer wird in den Jahrzehnten der Historisierung danach. Wir haben auch die ETA gehabt, also die Terrororganisation, die Menschen getötet hat für ihr Ziel einer Loslösung. Die hatte einige Hundert Mitglieder, aber eben auch zehntausende Sympathisanten. Und da wurden auch Entführungen und Attentate im Stadion von Athletik zum Teil auch gut geheißen. Und das ist jetzt auch lange her, die ETA gibt es nicht mehr. Mittlerweile ist wieder, das wird man auch wissen, Athletik Belbao spielt nur mit baskischen Spielern. Das wäre so, als wenn der 1. FC Nürnberg nur mit Franken spielt. Also sehr, sehr seltsam, hält sich seit mehr als 80 Jahren in der Primärrevision.
Es wird ja auch so, Entschuldigung, wenn ich da kurz reingehe, aber das finde ich ist so ein typisches Beispiel für ein einerseits, andererseits. Denn das wird ja auch sehr verklärt und gefeiert von vielen Fußballfans, die ich kenne. Und ich hatte auch immer so eine besondere Sympathie dafür, weil sich Athletik Belbao damit ja besonders schwer macht und weil man sich das gleichzeitig vielleicht auch so ein bisschen für den eigenen Verein wünschen würde, dass es mehr mit Spielern aus der Region gearbeitet wird. Dass das aber im Grunde ja ein Nationalismus in seiner Reihenform ist und dass das auch negative Konsequenzen hat für Spieler, die sich dagegen entscheiden, für Belbao zu spielen. Das wird dabei immer ein bisschen ausgeblendet.
Ja, das musste ich auch erstmal in meinen Kopf reinbekommen. Ich war in Belbao und war auch in Katalonien, weil ich den FC Barcelona oder einige Fans getroffen habe. Weil Nationalismus aus deutscher Perspektive ist immer erst mal rechts. Aber die Katalanen verstehen sich als sehr europäisch und als sehr weltoffen und eben auch als nationalistisch. Ähnlich wie die Schotten zum Beispiel. Die Schotten wollen sich ja von der Krone lösen. Viele wollen zumindest auch gegen den Brexit gehen und sehen sich dann auch manchmal als links und eben nicht als... Trotzdem heißt die Scottish Nationalist Party eigentlich eine sozialdemokratische Partei. Kurz als Schwenk. Und in Bilbao ist es manchmal auch so. Stimmt. Also ich habe mit Sid Lowe gesprochen, das ist der Korrespondent des Guardian für den spanischen Fußball. Und der sagte auch, er findet das sympathisch. Das ist so ein erdverwachsener Fußball, der leicht irgendwie an dem man sich andocken kann. Und es ist ja auch in keiner Regel festgeschrieben. Sonst wäre es vielleicht ein Problem für das Verfassungsgericht. Diskriminierung. Gab auch immer mal wieder rassistische Ausfälle gegen schwarze Spieler. Jetzt gibt es einen der größten Stars von Athletik, Inyaki Williams, der ein schwarzer Spieler ist, der Wurzeln hat. Seine Eltern aus Afrika kommen und sein Priester, Inyaki, deswegen wurde er so genannt, ist aber im Baskengland aufgewachsen. Kann man darüber sprechen, ob man das sympathisch findet oder nicht, aber es trägt zu der Mystifizierung dieses Clubs bei. Und wie gesagt, die anderen Punkte wie ETA-Verklärung oder wir kennen noch Bichente Lissardazou, der ist auf der französischen Seite des Baskenglandes groß geworden, war lange beim FC Bayern, der auch sogar eine Schutzsteuerzahnmuster an die ETA. Also es gibt auch die dunkleren Seiten in Bilbao und um den Burgen nochmal zu schließen, wegen der Nicht-Garantie für Zuschauer durch Corona hat die UEFA Bilbao die Spiele entzogen. Sie finden jetzt in Sevilla statt und ich habe mal nachgehört und nachgeschaut, viele Leute im Baskengland freuen sich darüber, dass die EM jetzt doch an ihnen vorbeigeht.
Und das ist auch der Grund, warum es jetzt dann hier in dieser Sendung gelandet ist. Ehrlicherweise hätte ich das ganz gerne mal gesehen, wie sich das geäußert hätte. Aber das kann jetzt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen der Zynismus des Unbeteiligten sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu sehr verharmlose. Also das sind separatistische Bewegungen, die wir aktuell noch haben. Du hast ja auch noch Cataloni genannt. Das sind nochmal ganz eigene Themenkomplexe für sich. Ich möchte jetzt nicht, wenn ich das jetzt alles in einen Kapitel packen, möchte ich damit nicht suggerieren, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das wäre alles dasselbe. Sondern wir können jetzt aber auch nicht bei allem so in die Tiefe gehen. Dann sitzen wir hier noch drei Stunden. Und dann haben wir den Nationalismus. Da hatten wir vorhin mit Manuel Neuer eigentlich schon so ein bisschen die Brücke, über die ich dann aber zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht gehen wollte, in ehemaligen Ländern von Jugoslawien, in dem der Fußball eine ganz krasse Rolle spielt und in dem das auch immer wieder aufflammt, wo es aber meiner Einschätzung nach wegen der Komplexität der Ereignisse da und auch wegen des vorhandenen Nichtwissens, also ich muss mir immer wieder neu anlesen, wie da jetzt eigentlich welche Unabhängigkeit genau verlief und welche Kriege es da genau gab, habe ich immer so das Gefühl, dass man oft Dinge auch gar nicht versteht, wenn man von außen drauf guckt. Und die großen Symboliken, die versteht man, also wenn ein Panzer neben einem Fußballstadion steht und sich die Fans eines Vereins damit ablichten, dann verstehe ich auch, dass da etwas zelebriert wird, was vielleicht mit Dingen zu tun hat, die ich nicht so gut finde und dass das auf einen Krieg referiert. Aber viele andere Symboliken versteht man gar nicht, die zu tun hat. Auch da hilft dein Buch an der Stelle sehr weiter. Und weil wir jetzt ja auch Teilnehmer aus Ländern des ehemaligen Jugoslawiens haben, habe ich das Gefühl, es hat eben doch auch für diese EM eine Relevanz. Ist das nochmal so ein ganz eigener Kosmos, das, was dort unten passiert ist? Also dort unten, Entschuldigung, ein bisschen salopp, aber ihr wisst, wie ich es meine.
Ich würde deine Wahrnehmung absolut teilen. Das war die große Frage. Ich war im Sommer 2019 drei Wochen auf dem westlichen Balkan. Ich habe genauso wie du gedacht, wer war da eigentlich gegen wen, warum haben die sich bekriegt? Und der sozialistische Jugoslawien war so ein spannendes Land, was ja anscheinend für ein sozialistisches Land gar nicht so schlecht funktioniert hat, bis es dann eben in den 80er Jahren durch Wirtschaftskrisen und Spannungen dann doch zu einem zu vielen Nationalismen kam. Und wo hat sich das zuerst gezeigt? Natürlich in den Fußballstadien. Und ich war in Belgrad, in Zagreb. Ich war auch in Kosovo und in Bosnien. Aber vielleicht bleiben wir bei Belgrad, also der Hauptstadt von Serbien. Der rote Stern Belgrad. Da haben sich Anfang der 90er Jahre schon viele Hooligans versammelt. Es gab da diesen legendären Fan-Anführer Raznatović, genannt Akan, der sogar Hooligans rekrutiert hat, die dann in den Krieg gezogen sind, gegen Kroaten, später dann gegen Bosnier, die auch an Kriegsverbrechen beteiligt waren, Vergewaltigungen, Morde. Viele von denen sind durchgekommen. Die wurden nicht strafrechtlich belangt. Raznatović selbst auch und ich, der ist dann später erschossen worden, weil er vermutlich zu viel wusste für die politischen Machthaber. Und heute, du hast den Panzer angesprochen, den habe ich auch gesehen. Da kommen dann die Papas, setzen ihre Kinder auf den Panzer, machen Fotos und Selfies. Das war ein Panzer, der Anfang der 90er Jahre auch in Kroatien beim Krieg aktiv war. Also diese Verharmlosung des Krieges, diese Verhälichung von Kriegsverbrechern. Ratko Bladić, der ging ja gerade wieder durch die Schlagzeilen. Lebenslanger Haft, nachdem er ja spät erst festgenommen wurde, verantwortlich für das Massaker von Srebrenica in Bosnien 95, für den Tod von 8000 Bosnien. Der wird schon noch verklärt und glorifiziert in Stadien Serbiens. Da sieht man auch Bilder von ihm, oder der wird besungen. Das ist das eine. Ich will das jetzt nicht nur, es gibt auch in Serbien auch Kritische, aber erst mal als Einstieg. Aber auch dann war ich in Sarajevo. Das empfehle ich jedem, Sarajevo, die Hauptstadt von Bosnien. Total spannend, nicht nur, weil das Stadion an der Front des Krieges lag, weil man immer noch die Geschichte da sehr nah wahrnehmen kann, sondern weil die Fußballfans das sehr kreativ und offensiv in die Gedenkkultur einnehmen. Also Fans, die getötet wurden während des Krieges, Spieler und so weiter, werden dort aufgegriffen und werden dort einbezogen in die eigene Geschichtsschreibung. Das gilt für Belgrad, das gilt für Sarajevo, auch für Zagreb. Da muss man nur mal mit großen Augen durch die Städte gehen. Graffitis sind da, Wandmalereien, eine sehr detailverliebte Art. Für jeden Fan lohnt sich das mal, so eine Tour zu machen durch den westlichen Balkan.
Und jetzt hast du ja mit Kroatien zum Beispiel auch schon einen WM-Teilnehmer genannt, wo wir das ja auch direkt erlebt haben. Bei der Feier der Vize-Weltmeisterschaft nach der WM 2018 war der Sänger von Thomson einer rechtsnationalen bis rechtsradikalen, meiner Einschätzung nach, Band mit auf dem Wagen der Nationalspieler und durfte mit denen feiern. Da darf ja dann durchaus nicht jeder mit dabei sein. Wie formuliere ich das? Ich will jetzt nicht wieder den Finger rausholen, auch weil ich so zu wenig weiß. Das muss ich einfach zugeben rund um die Balkankriege, die da stattgefunden haben und auch der Vorgeschichte, die ja oft auch noch mit Ethnien zu tun hat, wo ja die Vorgeschichte dann gar nicht jetzt irgendwie im 20. Jahrhundert liegen, sondern noch viel viel früher. Da bin ich einfach nicht tief genug drin. Aber ist das ein problematischer Bereich für dich, dass bei diesen Nationen dann eben auch im Kontext von Europameisterschaften dieser Nationalismus so verherrlicht ausgelebt werden kann?
Es ist wirklich total spannend. Also ich kann jedem das Buch von Richard Mills, ein toller britischer Historiker empfehlen, The Politics of Football in Jugoslavia. Der hat das eigentlich super erzählt. Auch Dario Brentin ist ein anderer Forscher aus Graz. Der hat auch das toll erforscht. Das fand ich eh spannend. Bei jedem Land so viele mittlerweile Autoren, Forscher, Wissenschaftlerinnen, die sich da wirklich toll mit befassen. Und das leider nicht so diese Öffentlichkeit bekommen, die sie eigentlich verdienen. Aber Kroatien ist ein gutes Beispiel. Da kann man ganz lange zurückschauen, auch schon vor dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, wie die Kroaten sich manchmal benachteiligt geführt haben gegen die Serben oder dann auch später, als Kroatien sich auch unabhängig erklärt hat, eine erfolgreiche EM 96, eine erfolgreiche WM 98, die junge kroatische Nation, diese Schachbrettmuster, das Trikot, was plötzlich bekannt geworden ist. Der Präsident damals von Kroatien, Franjo Tutschmann, für den Fußball so ein wichtiges Werkzeug war, der jungen Nation, der hat dann immer gesagt, der Sozialismus, das war eine Epoche, die wollten wir gar nicht. Und da wurden dann auch Parallelen gezogen zu der Zeit während des Zweiten Weltkrieges, ja, als Kroatien teilweise auch mit den Nazis kollaboriert hat. Hoseb Simonic, der frühere Hertha-Spieler, der auch so diesen faschistischen Gruß mal im Stadion gemacht hat. Der Nationalismus ist das schon ausgeprägt in Kroatien. Ich habe da in Zagreb auch eine Fangruppe, eine der wenigen kritischen linken, antirassistischen Gruppen auch besucht, die immer auch Sorge haben, ob sie nicht attackiert werden oder ob sie sich in Gruppen bewegen und kein Risiko eingehen wollen. Dinamo Zagreb, der größte Club. Dinamo, das ist ein Name, der an den Sozialismus erinnert. Tutschmann, der Präsident, der hat auch den Namen umbenannt. Der Club, der sich noch erinnert, die älteren, der hieß ja mal vorübergehend Kroatia Zagreb. Die Fans sind sturmgelaufen. Tutschmann hat gesagt, wer diesen Namen Dinamo weiter sagt, das ist ein Agent aus Belgrad. Als Tutschmann gestorben war, hat man diesen Club aus Kroatia Zagreb, wie den Dinamo Zagreb umbenannt. Das sieht man. Viele rechtsoffene Fans nutzen diesen Namen, der an das sozialistische Jugoslawien erinnert. Vieles passt nicht zusammen, aber dann wird passend gemacht. Das ist das Interessante am Fußball, nicht nur in Kroatien.
Ach, es ist ein komplexes Thema. Um das zu einem vorläufigen Ende in dieser Sendung zu führen, nach all den Dingen, die du angesprochen hast, und wir konnten viele Themenbereiche auch nur anreißen, vielleicht fällt es auf fruchtbaren Boden da draußen. Ich werde auch die von dir angesprochenen Lektüren unter anderem in den Show-Notes verlinken. Dein Buch habe ich jetzt schon oft genug empfohlen, das kommt natürlich auch noch mit rein. Was würdest du denn jetzt für ein Fazit ziehen bezogen auf diese EM? Ich hatte vor dieser Sendung EM der Autokraten zu nennen. Kann man das so stehen lassen? Oder picke ich mir da nicht vielleicht auch einfach etwas leicht Kritisierbares heraus und es ist dann vielleicht doch gar nicht so problematisch zu sehen, wie es der Titel vielleicht suggeriert?
Ich glaube, wir haben ganz gut die Waage gehalten, dass wir da nicht nur negativ waren. Bei mir war es so, dass ich als Sportreporter echt mal eine Zeit hatte, wo ich auch keine Lust mehr hatte auf diese kommerzielle Branche. Und ich für die letzten vier, fünf Jahre mir diese internationalen Themen auch suche, weil ich Lust habe, über den Fußballpolitischen Entwicklung in Ländern mir zu erschließen und hoffe, dass es auch einem größeren Publikum auch gefällt. Und wie gesagt, auch in autokratischen Ländern gibt es immer auch interessante, Ja, China, selbst Katar in den Golfstaaten, ich bin dahin gereist und bin danach immer auch differenziert zurückgekommen und manchmal mit noch mehr Fragen als Antworten. Es ist immer ein ganz tolles Gefühl, in ein Land zu reisen und zu merken, die eigenen Vorurteile werden gebrochen. Das ist toll. Wir haben auch zum Beispiel Glasgow einen Spielort. Wenn man da die Geschichte sieht, Celtic Glasgow katholisch geprägt, die Glasgow Rangers protestantisch, das spielt der Nordirland-Konflikt noch eine Rolle. Wir haben die Besonderheit, ich möchte es kurz erwähnen, dass das Land Großbritannien, ein Land, eine Staatsbürgerschaft, aber vier Nationalteams hat, England, Schottland, Wales, Nordirland und drei davon sogar für die EM qualifiziert sind, zwei England und Schottland in London gegeneinander spielen werden. Da ist so viel Geschichte dabei, da ist Religion dabei, da ist natürlich auch Frotzelei dabei. Und da wird über Brexit gesprochen, über Nordirland und es gibt uns eine Möglichkeit, über so vieles zu sprechen und das ist doch total total toll. Und wenn ich so in die internationalen Medien schaue, dann hat das eine Reichweite mittlerweile und es gibt mittlerweile so viele tolle Podcasts wie deinen, wo dafür einfach Öffentlichkeit hergestellt wird. Und ich glaube, dass als, ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen älter als du, als ich angefangen habe Fußball-Fans zu sein, da war das überhaupt nicht der Fall. Und jetzt haben wir sozusagen das Schulbuch Fußball, was gar nicht so sehr wie Schule wirkt, sondern was Spaß macht. Und das ist doch eigentlich für die kommenden vier Wochen nicht der Schlechteste.
Das heißt, so sollten wir es sehen. Wir genießen die EM, wir hinterfragen aber auch und nehmen es zum Anlass, dann uns an dem, was wir da sehen, fortzubilden. Und dann ist es wie die Netflix-Doku, die uns auf einmal in ein Thema reingezogen hat. Und plötzlich wissen wir alles über Kochen. Und so ist es dann mit Fußball und Politik auch, ja?
In der Tat. Und es macht ja auch Spaß, das mit Freunden zu machen. Also ich freue mich darauf. Wobei manchmal die Erfahrung war auch so, dass sobald so ein Turnier erst mal wieder läuft, rollt er nur noch der Ball. Vielleicht ist es... Wir haben ja einige Jahre auch davor gehabt, in dem wir darüber sprechen könnten. Und die große Hoffnung ist, dass man vielleicht nach der WM-Cutter, nach der EM, teilweise in Baku auch vielleicht noch mal danach hinschaut und das nicht vergisst.
Das ist doch ein schönes Schlusswort. Ronny, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich. Es ist nicht ganz deine Uhrzeit, hast du zum Anfang dieses Gesprächs gesagt. Ich vermute, es wurde nicht noch mehr zu deiner Uhrzeit. Umso mehr. Ganz herzlichen Dank für deine Zeit, dass du hier mit dabei warst im Rasenfunk.
Vielen Dank, dass du dem Thema so ein Forum gibst. Und ja, jetzt bin ich eigentlich noch hell wach und ich hoffe, dass ich der höhere, viele höhere Bands vielleicht auch morgens oder in der Mittagszeit hören. Aber es sei gesagt, wir nähern uns Mitternacht und wir arbeiten hier noch spät am Abend für das Publikum. Aber ich hoffe, dass das Publikum das Mittags- oder Morgens-Hört wach und frisch und voller Geduld.
Sie werden es sogar erst morgens hören können. Ich musste zwischendurch die Entscheidung treffen, da morgen früh wieder Schule ist für die Zwillinge, kann ich nicht mehr heute Nacht veröffentlichen. Also es wird erst morgen Vormittag erscheinen. Sie werden es mit frischem Kopf hören müssen. Ronny Blaschke, Ed Ronny Blaschke auch auf Twitter. Ich empfehle euch sehr, folgt ihm dort. Es lohnt sich und lest seine Bücher. Sie wurden nicht ohne Grund ausgezeichnet. An der Stelle ist vielleicht auch nochmal der Hinweis auf den Podcast Fußball und Macht zu machen, bei dem du ja auch involviert warst. Den haben wir schon mal vorgestellt, aber auch den werde ich nochmal verlinken. Ich werde auch ganz viele andere Bücher in den Show Notes verlinken als Anschub dann für eure Weiterbildung. Danke dir, lieber Ronny. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich hoffe, dieses Tribünengespräch hat euch gefallen. Wir freuen uns sehr über Feedback unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und dann bin ich doch sehr gespannt, wie wir diese EM dann alle konsumieren werden und was wir eigentlich zur WM22 dann hier im Rasenfunk machen. Da bin ich immer noch unentschlossen. Da hat der Ronny jetzt auch wieder dafür gesorgt, dass ich wieder neue Gedanken dazu hatte. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Wir hören uns hier im Rasenfunk. Passt auf euch auf. Bis bald. Macht's gut.
Das war das Rasenfunk Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Punkthäuser.